devant les craintes le gouvernement
fédéral qui tarde à annoncer son plan a
passé la journée à rassurer les
canadiens nous serons responsables
nous nous assurerons que les vingt-cinq
mille réfugiés répondent à tous les
critères de sécurité
voilà que dans la foulée des événements
de paris le premier ministre de la
saskatchewan demande à justin trudeau de
réviser son échéancier nous devrions
prendre le temps de revoir l'évaluation
des mesures de sécurité dis bras droit
oui avant tout aux vérifications de
sécurité
pas de concession là dessus mais
également on maintient notre position
d'accueil met un engagement de 25 mille
c'est l'engagement de monsieur trudeau
le gouvernement fédéral est il obligé
d'aller si vite demande le maire de
toronto
il faut s'assurer de faire les choses
correctement qui a repoussé les
engagements qui avaient été pris par le
gouvernement libéral
pour le moment nous sommes convaincus
qu'on peut amener 25 mille réfugiés
avant le fin de l'année et ça dans un
contexte de sécurité et de santé
appropriés
alors nous n'avons pas l'intention d'un
repoussé à l'échéancier la sécurité est
un immense défi mais des procédures
rigoureuses sont en place explique cet
expert
déjà le haut commissariat aux réfugiés
de l'onu a fait des vérifications en
profondeur dans les camps une fois
qu'ils arriveront au canada dans des
bases militaires
les syriens devront se soumettre à des
évaluations additionnel et le canada a
beaucoup d'expérience en cette matière
explique wesley wark malgré la pression
le gouvernement reste ferme
les vingt-cinq mille réfugiés arriveront
avant le 1er janvier mais le plan
tardent à être dévoilés et chaque jour
qui passe rend le défi encore plus
difficile et si marc godbout radio
canada à ottawa